hello everybody my name is markiplier
there seems to be a common misconception
that Tyler this guy right here this guy
Tyler he's guy look at him spinning and
doing backflips and stuff like that
Tyler oh man he's his head just exploded
oh now he's a ghost that guy Tyler
there's a common misconception that he's
my editor and you'd be absolutely right
he is 100% my editor and I want to show
off all of his most amazing editing
skills possible and there's only one way
to celebrate Metz to release the balloon
wow there's so many in so many colors
there's every single color balloon that
the human mind can comprehend Tyler is
not my editor Ethan and Katherine are my
editors and I even edit my own stuff Amy
also edits and makes stuff in After
Effects but Tyler has never touched
premiere a day in his life
today we're going to change that I want
to point out this is not a punishment
even if you may think it's a punishment
we just want to encourage skill building
among our friends right we want to
encourage people to grow both of us
professionals and as people and just
because we work for 36 hours straight on
a date with markiplier and he went home
and slept and then came back in the
morning and didn't even have the common
courtesy to get us coffee does not mean
that it's a punishment we love him and
if you love your children throw them in
the deep end of the pool hi I'm Tyler
born and raised in Cincinnati Ohio grew
up and with Marc to an extent and 28
I've never edited anything video wise
before I can't wait to cheer him on and
definitely not judge his editing skills
this could be really great I can't wait
to see our little butterfly fly away hi
I'm Katherine I do a lot I do most of
the editing for Marc so when we first
had this idea we were going to give
Tyler
crash course now I've been offering to
give Tyler crash course and premiere on
how to edit marks videos but every time
I bring it up he's like nah we'll do it
later and so I just want to help here is
I was gonna I'm gonna show him how to do
all the basics and you just you kept
putting it off and now it it's it's here
the time has come and I'm just it hurts
to watch honestly
so go ahead okay oh wait before I do
that I want you to know that you are
being time use big clock over here right
here you serious if you say you have
ready I want to point out this isn't an
unfair time hold on in my logic open the
application if this is this time it
specifically meant because we've has
editors when we were making a date with
Mark Dwyer we roughly did about 24
videos and 36 hours which works out to
everyone doing a video every two hours
or so and that sounds pretty fair right
I think so I even gave you an extra
second new brush well what are you gonna
call it wasting precious time on the
name up what's so sure because you want
to make sure all your assets are in the
same place so if someone else has to
open the project all the assets aren't
just on your computer note I mean or in
a different folder with different from
yet oh whoa whoa whoa whoa here right by
your side well but I felt that on my
hair I hate you all pretty strong words
for a friend to say you know but to his
credit he did open a project he did
import the footage which are the two
easiest steps and take like five seconds
to do and he did it in five minutes
so do you know what that is
for everything there where you got the
audio you've got that no but I'm talking
about this thing here but that's your
timeline good good good
okay just learning I've no freakin Chloe
please no please this isn't even that
anything part
no not 720 it's got I can't just give it
huge try like I can to to set it up for
please can I do can I do what I was
supposed to do
you've got the footage and you've got
the gameplay and there are two separate
things he's done it good he's learning
he's learning
he's learning that's a very basic
there's gonna be a let's play like I did
a few years ago huh
no edits but correct format you getting
it ah you proud papa I made all the time
mmm Tyler Tyler you're getting it like a
nut I'm sweating I am legitimately
sweating because they are stressing me
the hell out even is talking to me like
I'm a freakin child not your child
older than you baby boy baby boy blue
and the timer is counting down right in
front of me as I'm doing this I think
I'm learning pretty quick so I'm kind of
proud of myself and give myself a pat on
the back and try not to stress out more
than that timer needs to stop mark stop
the timer
why please I'm not editing right now oh
you should be I asked you if you wanted
to say the word you said yes you do you
want me to give you a quick gesture okay
you want to activate this is a crash
course I can't get around because I
can't learn by watching I have to do
okay so
you're going to hit me too because you
want to activate that for your
presentation good
you don't you feel you don't need to
colic highly teaches high they let me
give time to crash course that I was
supposed to give them a couple days ago
I think he's going to do a really good
job he's really excited about it think
the biggest thing against him right now
is the clock and Ethan I think Tyler's
doing pretty good so far you know he's
got the beginning stuff down I'm excited
to see his fancy adage because he says
that he has ideas and I am also worried
that after this he just could be like Oh
editing is easy easiest thing in the
world because he walked into the
bathroom and said yes I'm ah I'm
learning real real quick it's ah it's
not that bad and then Catherine was like
yeah but this is the easiest part of the
editing so we decided to see what he has
to say about himself I'm kind of
noticing a power dynamic going on here
Ethan is a lot more threatened than I
thought he'd be by Tyler and admittedly
he has picked up quick
the clock is against him he's only got
about an hour 15 minutes left but yeah
even um I think all of his criticisms
are coming across as like defensive
because what if Tyler is better than him
I don't need three other degree five
four three two one
and puts blood down your pencils step
put it out put it out
tough out for that tell people huh
cheaters never win
you're like Tom Brady that Mouse is
looking rather just look at it is a good
cheating all right well shall we all
watch really nice yeah
all right all right whoa get out of your
Ronnie the Rhino you're not you're not
welcome here I'm a firm believer that
anyone can do anything if they put their
mind to it
show an infographic of every one of the
cumulative human thinking power process
like get it like a like a diagram that
perfectly represents human thinking
right here ah
so I'm going to do a very simple let's
play and it's very convenient that
there's no internet because I don't know
if you guys knew this this is actually a
game if you have no internet and you're
running out internet you can just play a
game so I'm just going to play this and
uh Tyler is just gonna edit it and he's
gonna do a great job [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] why did that scare me oh geez okay
anyway oh god what scared me was a
werewolf
oh now what what's really cool with this
game is once you get a hundred points a
laser light show starts from the ground
up and then shoots as a dubstep music
plays in the background okay so I hit
hundred points there you didn't see a
lot of it but this timing went to the
third time that you get a hundred points
instead of dubstep in the laser show its
fireworks exploding an eagle swooping in
and then bang in house music mixed with
a little bit of pop is coming in there
oh hang on wait while I'm playing this
[ __ ] while I'm playing this it's very
interesting because if you if you're
playing and you get a hundred points you
need to shoot a gun in the air and
squeal like a fang whoa the realistic
gun effects it's a real gun guys [ __ ]
so watch watch again now every every
every ten points after 100 once the
laser light show and the dubstep helped
music bang bang bang bang with every
jump bang bang and then confetti rain
from the ceiling bang bang bang oh wait
down there in the in the field just
below this there's a parade of like
hundreds of different colored elephants
look at the moco I can hardly count bang
I can hardly count how many there are
like I can how many one a hundred 25 27
whoo fish flowing in a river oh my god
is it raining in here holy [ __ ] is going
nuts in my house okay alright anyway
enough of that it's going to calm down
it's gonna this game is really crazy
guys we need to we need to step it down
a little bit because I need to get a
high score because that's what I do I
play games good and well and never badly
here comes a comical zoom up close-up of
my face with weird proportioned body
parts it wasn't that funny guys yeah I
was pretty funny wasn't it huh here
comes another zoom up of my face with
something else hilarious happening to me
wasn't that a good one
wait one more oh man tad Tyler he's such
a good editor yeah I have no idea what
he's doing here I'm just bizarre to be
all these random occurrences are coming
in the way of my perfectly normal and
understandable Let's Plays it's really
interesting because once I beat my high
score of 300 what will actually happen
is the whole game and video cuts away to
tyler crying in a bathtub that's just
like an ancillary faculty I don't know
what that has to do with this game but I
mean it just happens the Google program
is written it in there like that okay
alright huh
I think I think the game might have
calmed down a little character actor oh
did it okay now I'm actually
concentrating on this who I hope I hope
something else crazy happens while what
is that oh no I hope they don't get in
the way of my score it's a competing
dinosaur whoa okay then alright
apparently it's night now make my webcam
night too it's some cricket sound
effects in there oh is it a story
neither is it a cloudy night is it a
full moon I don't know okay well
apparently say no all right scratch all
that alright bring in the dancing girls
don't have time hundreds of them down to
the bottom just going for it they're
lovely they are Wow
okay alright now suddenly the game is
going to start turning multiple colors
all at the same time the music is going
to slowly pitch shift down
oh [ __ ] more balloons I'm getting the
ultimate high score
holy [ __ ] yep yep bloop
thank you thank you thank you let me let
me homeboy now I'm actually legitimately
concentrating because I kind of like
we're getting interesting now okay
ignore all the craziness that and before
because that has nothing to do with me
getting this ultimate high score why is
it shipping like how fast is the day off
[ __ ] [ __ ] ah look how funny it is
when I'm added it angry I'm turning into
the Hulk
okay so anyway that was Tyler's first
video that he's ever made Wow
wasn't that amazing now that showcases
the skill and power and women vigor of
everybody helps me make my videos but in
all honesty a Katherine and Ethan both
helped make my videos in addition to
myself I do a lot of editing myself but
they have taken on the brunt of the work
so that I can focus on making cool
videos myself and gridding new ideas out
there and all together like we have a
really good team and I'm really happy
that I have so many people that are
willing to try new things and help me
out in making these cool videos and
coming with me with my crazy stupid
ideas and coming up with their own crazy
stupid ideas like I'm honored to have
them be a part of their Santa and I'm
super happy that they're here and you
know it I just wouldn't be here without
them so I just have to say that I'm
super grateful to Tyler Eaton Katherine
and Amy for all helping me you know with
what I do and all making it so that you
guys get better videos so at the end of
the day that's what really matters so
thank you everybody so much for watching
I hope you enjoyed this and if you want
to see Tyler do something else I'm gonna
have him make an animation for me how's
that sound I don't know maybe something
like that you have an idea let me know
down the comment
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I'll see you in
the next video bye bye
so Tyler did better than I thought he
would if he had taken the crash course
before this venture he may have been
able to put more detail into be at it's
pretty good but for what they were like
conceptually they were there he was able
to attract motion keyframe stuff place
it correctly crop it out green-screen
like not bad I mean I would have made
the game the actual game video bigger so
people would see it not be a tiny
quarter of the screen but you know it's
their own so thank you everybody so much
for watching hope you enjoyed this
little video and as always we'll see you
in the next video bye bye
I wasn't paying attention it kind of
looked like [ __ ] I was too busy working